you
my grandfather he'd bring out the
binoculars and he'd teach us about the
sky no idea that I would be traveling to
the stars but here I am for decades
the Hubble Space Telescope has provided
us with unparalleled visions of the
universe but its future was in jeopardy
I go through the mission in my mind and
ask what could go wrong are we ready to
handle them on the final mission to
Hubble seven astronauts embarked on an
expedition to save it and an IMAX 3d
camera was on board to capture it
I'm looking out the window here and
unbelievably traveling around the planet
at 17,500 miles per hour the astronauts
of the space shuttle Atlantis have only
one chance to secure Hubble's future if
there's some risk that goes along with
achieving a dream I think it's worth it
if they fail we lose our window into
galaxies so distant their light has
taken billions of years to reach us the
Hubble Space Telescope allows us to go
to places so far away that it's
inconceivable that humans will ever go
there
[Applause]
[Music]
Warner Brothers pictures and IMAX and
cooperation with NASA invites you to
experience the wonder of the universe we
live in on an incredible IMAX 3d journey
through time in space
[Music]
Hubble shows us the size of the universe
in the beauty that it holds it's beyond
what we can comprehend Hubble 3d
narrated by Leonardo DiCaprio change
your view of our universe in IMAX 3d